okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are looking at functions
that are currently experimental emotion
language and we are discussing what it
will take to make them not experimental
and whether that will happen for the
upcoming new version all right let's
start with synthetic geometry so ah okay
so we've got some things that are purely
standard geometric operations like angle
bisector and so on and then we've got a
class of things that are much more our
specific um theorem proving in geometry
is that correct correct they're
improving stuff actually hasn't even
been released yet in 12 oh so no I mean
the the okay what's happening with that
stuff is that coming into twelve one on
what I'd we're gonna push back to talk
to you I think okay so my main issue
with things like angle bisector is the
concept of returning these symbolic
primitives I mean maybe it's like what
else could we do oh I mean you have
definitely more semantic meaning than a
set of vectors
oh yes so basically the infinite line
idea was that's the most useful thing
for using it inside of geometric seen
outside of geometric scene maybe maybe
there's so you know I like this behavior
I like it if you feed it you know feed
it undigested stuff it'll come out like
that and feed it digested stuff will
come out like that so to speak that
seems like a really good palette
everybody magically yeah I think that I
have found out over the past few weeks
that's a lot more controversial than I
thought and what which part of it the
the output part I think the accepting
the different types of inputs isn't Sur
controversial but having outputs differ
based on the head of the inputs I'm we
do that in many many places
I mean I don't think it that in and of
itself is the controversial point I
think the controversial point is I don't
think we have a consistent set of rules
for the different functions and the
different possible inputs fair enough
well that's what we should think about I
mean so angle bisector similarly I
personally don't like the fact that in
this case it's returning infinite line I
have no problem right what else would it
return well let's think about that for a
second ok so I mean if that was what
would that be I see that what the heck
is that I mean that's not even a line
well it sort of is a line I mean if that
was a line of those things then I am I
am confused here
right so right it's giving so in the
three point syntax is faking those as
the three points of an angle right so P
1 Q P 2 and then it's giving you the
infinite line and the forum those were
point if those had had point I would
have zero problem with this result even
if that was a line from those from that
to that to that I would have zero
problem with this result
my problem with this result I mean it is
miss midpoint behavior what's that if
you see it this way it is inconsistent
with the midpoint behavior where the
type of the output subtly depends on the
geometric primitives in the airport no I
think there's this midpoint look look at
what midpoint of the midpoint is if
there's raw coordinates it returns a raw
coordinate that's what I'm saying yeah
okay so now there's no raw coordinate
form of a line exactly this is a special
thing that only applies to midpoint
because we've got to well let's talk
about that for a second okay let's talk
about that for a second
I mean we could of course agree on one
right I mean let's talk about that to me
what angle bisector does with geometric
primitives is uncontroversially correct
if I put in and I would advise this as
as some and I really hate using these
scripting things for these but anyway
that's a different this year I mean you
know if I were to put you know point
into each of those I totally forget
where this is going to work or not
well I better work pictum look fine now
the next one is whether this works it
does great excellent but the question is
if you replace now point by line yeah
that should work in my opinion it
shouldn't right there should be two
separate lines this is like a polyline
that is Alexei digression like what do
we mean by line here do we mean line in
the sense of graphics primitives online
in the sense of geometric scenes right a
limit but polygons which I don't a line
in both cases don't we well so for
inside of geometric scene there's an
additional assumption that you do line
of ABC that it's a it's a straight line
so so this right well that it's really
kind of necessary because a lot of these
geometric seem I understand like exotic
meaning yeah so I feel like having angle
bisector work on on this sort of well
that rubs one's nose in that issue
yeah all right so hold on a second
before we go us over that you know a
polyline is not a polyline in geometric
scene as what you're saying correct or
it's a polyline where all the segments
are linear everybody done is a line in
German I see that's right that's the
basic point but um I I predict that's
gonna lead us into trouble somewhere and
I think we need to think more carefully
about that about the possibility that we
have somehow that we for example I mean
have we considered the possibility of a
you know a straight line concept we had
we had very early on in the synthetic
geometry project we had something called
line through which which is basically
how line works now inside geometric
scene where it's basically what you're
what you're proposing here with straight
line but we abandon it and just added
the assumption to line the issue be
straight line is it would be perfect for
dramatic scene and also perfect for
symbolic inputs what would it represent
if it has a set of points that aren't on
the sidelines well it's somewhere in a
circle through because Charles supports
circle through outside geometric scene
now
so whatever it does for that I think
would happen for straight line well it's
like like at each point would it give
error messages when used when trust
written down what does it do for circle
through this Charles here does I just
put random circle through I believe it
it doesn't error on symbolic no no I
understand that right I think it will
give you an error at evaluation zone
yeah not the right way around
[Music]
yeah perfect that is not a very good
error message there no circle can be oh
no no no no no it's a form you wouldn't
but but that's by the way that's a bad
message even regardless okay so for
three points were good it can go through
them right let's pick five points okay
that is a terrible error message come on
guys we can do better
no circle there no circle exists going
through a circle through blah blah blah
does not exist come on let's make it
literate please on the Charles I think I
imagine that he phrased it that way so
that would also apply for if you did
like I don't care I don't care Stephen
that's a different circle ooh for me the
names are just it makes a circle that
goes through so it does not trivial
evaluation where straight-line has for
me much more a similarity baseline which
just is a primitive that is in note it
sits there I agree
so that's why they're the error
detection mode is much more complicated
we don't agree if we added this thing
right it should presumably be line
through and which would for concrete
values would either evaluate to a line
or her out Charles is okay listen listen
I got a way to solve this um what if so
what circle through returns a circle as
you would expect if it can I understand
that what if we called it angle bisector
line and it returns a line that I know
infinite learn infinite line whatever by
the way I assume infinite line renders
and graphics okay yes it does I guess
see that down below
angle bisector line tells me I'm gonna
get a line out good I'm saying yeah and
and then you know and then well big
surprise I get a line I mean that will
be because cuz this I don't even know
what I would get out of this that's my
suggestion I wonder when we were
designing this when he were who we all
realized we didn't exactly know what an
angle bisector was physically so yeah I
didn't even know what angers a
completely different question so I like
this suggestion okay so for kind of
related issues if we go down to like
triangle triangle Hold'em but
perpendicular bisector so that would
have the same story right currently it's
just an infinite line so we can do
perpendicular bisector line although
this makes it I'm concerned of putting
line in there because it's not our line
primitive it's an infinite line right
that's okay it's a it's already gives
the idea that it's a line no I would
argue this so does being called angle
bisector and perpendicular bisector well
not to me it doesn't I would agree with
that for a perpendicular bisector I'm
not sure I would agree with that for
angle bisector right i but I think
perpendicular bisector and angle
bisector have to have this a have to be
parallel
I mean we've we thought about higher
dimensions and these things could be
hyper planes and all kinds of crazy
things that is true in that in the
future great then they'll be cool to put
you know angle is gonna be blowing up
the site don't think that's right
because I think it's going to be a more
cut what is an angle in three you know
it's some dihedral angle somewhere I
mean what is it you know it's going to
be complicated to say what you mean by
that
that
you know you see what I'm saying right
and also you know until we have
something that works in 3d this will
emphasize that this will not work in 3d
well that wouldn't be I wouldn't give
that argument my main argument is if I
saw angle bisector line
I know roughly what it's gonna give line
infinite line I don't know the
difference but angle bisector you said
what is that gonna give I don't know
maybe it gives the angle divided by 2 I
don't know Roger you you seem to agree
with me I do okay all right
I was so for triangle construct we have
some string arguments that I think
involved you know angle bisectors and
and perpendicular bisectors and related
things so you might want to have a look
at those okay let's take a look at that
hold on I just want to okay I just want
a perpendicular bisector line yeah I
like this and the midpoint doesn't have
a capital P now I admit that that's a
slightly you know you get what I'm
saying
okay well you can it be difficult right
no that's the right thing it's the right
thing this is midpoint doing what it's
doing right now is the right thing also
one other thing on midpoint is if you if
your inputs one is a naked list of
coordinates and the other has head point
it I forget whether it's it returns a
naked list or with head point but it it
does return something which I would like
to confirm is okay
it's okay try it the other way around
oh wow no I'm gonna do something more
exotic right it only works then - what
do you get it Oh Oh for the first one a
point for the second one yeah so I think
it yeah it that whatever that seems
quite sensible some dough cheek do it
right yeah okay so listen another thing
that I would like to suggest an
operation that I want with remarkable
frequencies I want to go a certain
distance between two points a certain
fraction of the way between two points
so like a parametric yeah I want to be
able to give a second argument let's say
- midpoint although that's a kind of a
weird idea so you would the point or the
the segment you walked along you weren't
at the point right I want the point okay
right I think you're actually discussed
this a while ago and I mean I need that
operation so many times I mean I'm I'm
just kind of wondering if there should
be a parameter you know alpha or
something it's a second argument -
midpoint with default value 1/2 you need
this for just a line or for a general
curve I think I've needed it just for
points a zillion times I mean it you
know it's obviously you know it's
obviously an easy computation but it's
kind of a nuisance right now you gotta
go right yeah I think I think trying to
expand this to anything beyond two
points is just like right away any
rectifiable curve or whatever so yeah it
within two points yeah we discussed this
and I think just the main issue was what
was the name so we just stuck with
midpoint without it but it would
certainly be easy to implement
I would like to [ __ ] okay but I think
with keeping it midpoint with an
optional second argument which we call
like the fraction or something yeah
that's what I would suggest that's what
I'm suggesting all right I'll be right
maybe as ow also numbers also then form
the interval 0 1 2
sure right so Luna okay okay um two
comments from my livestream here from
Bob say he likes the name line through
and also suggesting angle bisecting line
I don't think it sounds as good as angle
bisector line that's similar to what we
have in triangle construct yeah you're
gonna and when you pull up that could
you pull up the source ref page for
which triangle construct as opposed to
the builds page yeah sander on
livestream suggesting a scaled well
actually this is scaled in a sense this
is scaled midpoint thing is oh I see he
says he was about to make a line part
function for the function repository
which with a scaled option I see which
is which is the same type of idea this
would be you know the parameter and
midpoint would be a scaled thing from
zero to one unskilled sees on those
points very clever like because you
might go one in this direction or if
it's a grant by the forest Kate we
cannot unskilled I don't follow that oh
yeah he's saying on the on the line go
distance one on the line from the
initial point I see food would be
automatic which is exactly the distance
for may to be I said by two well I think
versus a ratio personally I think that
the that Sanders go that distance on the
line thing line part I'm not sure line
part is my absolutely favorite name for
it but I think that will be a fine
function repository thing I think from
midpoint it's got to be a parametric
fraction here by the way does midpoint
work for three-dimensional things it
certainly should
I think Charles heads and some opinions
on whether these things should work in
3d I think midpoint does but the other
ones don't
yeah good
okay because because midpoint is is
unambiguous in any RN right mm-hmm
so what happens with line of a list of
points if you have more than two points
I just don't know the answer to this
[Music]
well does it only work if they're
collinear if it's a jagged line I
implemented this long enough ago I do
not remember what happens I maybe just
ignores the ones in the middle I don't
know what does it give an out well I can
look up the code on the line
all right that's right because if the
thing is that if the line doubles back
over itself then you can't just go you
can't add up the distances and go so
basically the region's stuff if a lion
doubles back over itself it doesn't
consider it parametrically where you're
moving back it just considers considers
just the geometric object so I have to
call region centroid in case there's a
whole bunch of double backing or
whatever but does it only work on the
straight line case I use region centroid
will generally put it off the line if
it's turning right but what is the the
midpoint of you know something that
doubles back and the exactly's interest
rate but yeah I wasn't really
comfortable with putting this in right
yeah a lot of sense to me I don't
remember what the I can look I don't
even understand why we support this at
all that was my argument was not signed
I don't weave dynamically well well so I
know midpoint of a line with two points
is fine but midpoint of a line with
endpoints just doesn't seem like you
know I don't think Euclid would have
talked about that it doesn't seem to me
to be very meaningful okay I think maybe
the reason we we have that is because
again inside of geometric scene
of you know five points is a straight
line so this is meaningful and something
someone might want to actually excelled
a dog you it's pretty you know yes but
in the case of a concrete line there's
all kinds of machine epsilon e type
stuff and so on right
but if we replace line with line through
four inside of geometric scene then you
know it's problem solved right but you
I've got a few cones from live stream
Bob is mentioning the name point lerp
but I do not know what that is
I've if there is a thing called alert
I've never heard of it leop live-action
role-playing no oh linear interpolation
loop
oh well basic operation of in graphics
jog and it's called a loop I did not
know that unless that's somebody faking
out Wikipedia in some way um Wow
what do you know well yet another thing
LUNs that is an impressive figure if it
is which it probably isn't but well
apparently that's what it's called
hmm okay well that's certainly a keyword
that we should have thank you um yeah I
mean that's exactly the operation we're
talking about here uh so did you want to
look at that triangle construct I do
want to look at the triangle construct
there's also a question on lighting
about whether interpolation works on
points I'm okay let's look at triangle
construct the source ref age I mean oh
the source reference that oh my gosh
this is a super function yep look at all
these creatures
okay so draw your attention to angle
bisector and angle bisecting C bein one
being just a line what does altitude
okay so what are these things actually
return so you know I really wish you
wouldn't use these blasted
incomprehensible obscure scripty symbols
for things why are you doing that I was
following the example of other geometry
pages great they use script R for region
and things like that well that's
different it's a capital R and you can
actually see it here this just looks
like a little glitch item there and the
page to me what is that thing anyway can
I change that to just say alt equals
capital L it would be better no what is
it why would you call anything a script
lowercase L because it's all why oh boy
I would just call it line or something
really I just think that that raises a
sort of cognitive level for people of
you know what is that is that math is
that something else
anyway we'll change it yeah
problem is the non script elves this
looks like a one so and why do you have
to name ISIL because you're gonna use
the triangle agraria um although you
could always just use percent rate and
percent percent right yeah yeah you
gonna name the triangle unfortunately
here okay so so this thing in this case
you're telling me that you are returning
for the altitude here you are returning
something that is graphics friendly and
you are whoops
right serve try old construct always
returns something graphics friendly so
if there's like if thing in constructors
the point it has a head point okay I had
forgotten that the right name here is
triangle construct not triangle
construct although if you if your
optional argument is triangle then it
will construct the triangle when you
construct the triangle which optional
argument this one this one right so if
you that's just because if you are if
you didn't have a triangle now you have
a head triangle object right and if you
omit the and that's the default if you
omit that argument okay you know what
else could it possibly do okay so you
say by the way there's no water complete
here there was no other completed all
here somebody needs to fix that that's
missing source notebook tagging if you
don't know how to do that okay yeah okay
that's a beautiful infinite line is that
a problem with that that should be fine
I think the reason we're discussing
whether is whether we should have this
also changed angle bisector line I know
too
so I want to say there's another thing
you could put there which is angle
bisecting CVN right CBN's her
had some awkward names just because
there are lots of I never knew about
sealians until we were doing this
project right so I'm not super thrilled
with this what does it even mean
so CBN is from devian is in a triangle
huh is a line that has one endpoint as a
vertex of the triangle and it's other
endpoint in the opposite side and it can
be defined by a point in the Triangle
goes through it could be defined by so
what's the default seat in an argument
and you use the centroid right second
point your drug going to it okay fun
yeah I remember that
okay so what is this so this is going it
uses randomly the second one of these on
the centroid you're saying but it's not
random because they're like angle
bisector for example whoa well default
to the second and for anything else
there's no preferred to default so might
as well use the second for everything
right okay so the thing that concerns me
I mean altitude doesn't say altitude
line even though it is a line right an
angle bisector I would say don't bother
to say line here okay I think that that
we can make it work in addition well
also but don't put any also the fact
that triangle construct always returns
you know graphics friendly thing should
should clue people and yes I agree I
don't see a problem with that okay so
also just to point out so triangle
Center for all of the all of the string
arguments for triangle construct that
return a point you can use those as
arguments for triangle center but
triangle Center always returns the naked
coordinates this is just something where
when we were doing the design I think
you you know the center's were an
important enough part that it you
thought they needed their own head yeah
I thought I should just return
coordinates okay good that's what
happens yes there's no there's no point
you have to say point of triangle Center
if you want the triangle center point so
to speak okay good and similarly
triangle measurement is not returning
you know presumably triangle measurement
is mostly returning numbers and only
remember in space
I think triangle Center yeah can we
circle back to triangle construct for
yes so in the details and options
section towards the bottom I had a
different proposal on how to specify
what form of angle bisector to have Yeah
right there the line type oh my god what
kind of lumps yeah we talked about this
I feel like by the way why is it an
infinite line I don't understand why
doesn't a half line in the case of the
generic angle bisector line well because
you half line makes the you know value
judgment that it should either go
through the you know the smaller ain't
it should be you know what directions
was a half line point that's why you
have an interior and exterior all right
well also in a lot of constructions I
mean you do the angle bisector and then
you talk about the supplementary angles
I mean it is a useful thing but what's a
useful thing the infinite line of the
half line the infinite line okay I don't
think we have a good story here on
choosing whether you want the infinite
line or the half line or just a line
segment and we're not doing it the same
way in triangle construct and with the
stand alone angle bisector function I
think is right because in a right
because in the sense angle bisecting cvn
is what should be called well I guess we
have an extra that we have more data
here because it's a triangle and not
just an angle that's the thing that sort
of returns a line yeah
whereas people are going to probably
have heard line and not have heard of
see bian
okay so hold on a second so I'm now
concerned about the angle bisector line
thing no matter it returns half lines or
or infinite lines I think you want you
want infinite line half line and a line
segment
what's the line segment for it's if
you're in a triangle you'll talk about
the angle bisector is specifically the
line segment from the vertex to the
opposite why doesn't angle bisector line
take a triangle as its first argument
exactly we've covering this in if you
want to do that right now it has to be
in triangle construct so I understand
but we could also make angle bisector
take triangle as a first argument it
work what are the second what are the
second arguments what's tight and tear
it or next area I don't even know one
this time what that means that that only
determines the direction of the infinite
line right that's an infinite line don't
be too different infinite lines that are
right angles to each other right it's
the exterior angle is the supplementary
angle to the angle I think you can go
down to the exterior angle bisects that
angle right I'm confused here
it's one of those things that exists in
geometry but the name is not exactly not
exactly what I understood was the
there's a you know there's a as an angle
formed by two lines right and there's
the bisector which goes in the middle of
those two lines and there's no way that
reference helped do well with an
illustration and we wouldn't even have
this discussion because you would get
right away what the concept was yes good
point this needs an illustration um as
do um I'm just amused by somebody on our
live stream saying that triangle Center
seems very ambiguous because there are
lots of triangle centers I yes
let's commend your attention to the
actual list of triangle centers and the
fact that you are required to give a
second argument to triangle Center which
says which one you are
you're talking about I don't really
centroid is yes centroids the default
other visit default why isn't the
default shown up here I don't think it's
super useful is there a separate thing
where you can ask for centroid regions
intro yeah I think you should show that
default that again I think it is useful
yeah and generally speaking we've moved
in the direction of if there is a
default value for the argument we showed
the walk you know the one argument form
in the main usage cuz that okay so will
we do the same on triangle construct the
one argument form is equivalent to just
know the completely silly one argument
form that nobody would ever use whereas
triangle Center is one argument form
that people might actually care about
okay in that case I would put it as a
subsidiary thing don't forget to tag it
for syntax colouring and so on right
yeah okay so I want to come back to how
a friend angle bisector okay and I want
to understand in what sense I am now
totally confused okay so here's a pair
of I mean I don't know why you show this
example which is which is which has many
additional confusions because it's a I
mean why don't you show an example which
doesn't have a right angle here I think
you need to do that okay okay don't show
a right angle but but anyway so there's
an infinite line that is going now what
I would understand is the exterior angle
would be this angle here is that wrong
that so for unsired right but this
earlier your notion is what we call full
exterior angle right if you look at the
at the just tell me what you're saying
that the exterior angle is some bizarre
thing where it is it's the supplementary
angle right with respect to which we
initial line in planner angle we try to
explain it doesn't matter right the
bisecting the infinite line will be the
same in either one yeah one planar angle
yeah planar angle has an explanation
because it's just the definition in
geometry I need to exist in the other
one as well right yes which was like
that okay right so that is another yeah
there's enough interior/exterior in full
exterior you scroll past it yeah no I'm
looking at the examples yeah planar
angle is the angle holistic this is the
angle that some counterclockwise angle
formed by those things at that point
right don't default is a smaller angle
so the angle less than pi oh so it's not
a counterclockwise angle right you can
add in yeah yeah you can add in the
string argument okay what does it do by
default it just picks the smallest one
the default interior yes which is
defined as the smallest the one formed
by that trial yeah in the interior of
that triangle okay
so bizarrely exterior and I probably
should have been paying more attention
in my geometry class fifty years ago or
something today
no that is that angle there okay yeah so
that means that the bisector in is could
be there or could be the perpendicular
right
yeah that's an argument in favor of
keeping it infinite line because for
instance for the you know the exterior
angle there are you know you could pick
that one you could pick the other one
the infinite line you know works for
both of them yeah it's just a matter of
be clear about what what angle are you
specifying in plan angle we try to make
it clear why even with the same tax hole
where you say P goes to Q q1 q2 you have
to really specify which angle is it the
interior one or they still your wall
even though those two syntaxes are
effectively equivalent
let me try to peek shouldn't you support
this syntax an angle bisector line
because that would be the from that
point to those other points it's the
same story as with planar angle as JJ I
forget whether we redoing that we didn't
okay and the in the at least it's not
documented whether or not that were
definitely not documented i I just I
haven't I heard that up a long time ago
so I don't remember whether I actually
supported that all right so let's come
back again to this question so an angle
here notice by the way the angle has no
units which is the right thing because
most of our angles don't have units um
no no that's that's a form I did the
statements Kuwait but the argument is
form okay angus to object angle measure
hist units oh boy this is a famous issue
right Michael can you give the one
sentence summary or two sentence summary
of the whole question about whether
radians should be a base unit no that's
not about but here we speak about the
objects a is on angle or a line and they
they have properties like lengths or
angles or like a pulley good has a
measure it's the area mm-hmm
that's why we have to a differentiate
between the anchor and the measure of
the angle what what is the angle well
desync right
couidn't the set of points well but
that's not what this is planar angles
returning a number right yes but but I
know but are these documented has the
length of the arc conceptually there's a
difference between an angle itself in an
angle measure but in the system we only
deal with angle measures all right okay
fine all right back to angle bisector so
clearly it has to be consistent with
planar angle right
I'll make those changes for the inputs
but I wouldn't document it first as it's
done in planar angle because I think
it's obscure for angle bisector I think
you're more thinking about it has a line
because not least because planar angle
deals with you know higher dimensional
things and all kinds of wild stuff but
angle bisector line I'm still okay first
of all I'm even more convinced that it
should say angle bisector line after
seeing but I'm now totally confused
about it could be a half line starting
at P in the in the case of the notation
a planar angle but it is in fact an
infinite line for reasons that I don't
fully understand okay so by always
returning an infinite line it sidesteps
the question of whether we're bisecting
the interior angle or o area angle right
but we still are confused by the
interior angle which is again arbitrary
because there are two interior angles
depending on which line we chose to make
be the base correct
David book are you talking about
counterclockwise versus clockwise I
guess I am right sides give the same in
right side surfaces yeah I mean even if
it was a half line it would still right
it still happens that that's you right
whether it's the clockwise or the
counterclockwise exterior angle it's
really just the big counterclockwise
right it with there are three angles we
need to worry about the interior angle
doesn't matter which base does the
bisector is to saying you know there's
the exterior where I suppose there if if
he decided to start trying it as Adel as
a ray rather than as a line then it
might matter which one we chose to
extend and then there's the sort of full
exterior angle where again it doesn't
matter
you know it would have to point in the
opposite direction as the interior angle
right right so I right so we could I
mean right this can right there this
convention is taking write q1 to p2 q2
and exterior is defined in a particular
way which I forget which side is right
we can look at the drawing for exterior
and see which way but I think it's
extending from q2 to P and then finding
that angle
well that exterior it's the measure so
it doesn't matter a turn we choose oh
you went to a different page if you do
the infinite line it doesn't matter
which one right yeah eat I was talking
about like on a planar angle I thought
but since finer angle returns the
measure doesn't matter which which which
orientation we choose it's just what
picture we use for the documentation why
doesn't plan on angle huh basis why
isn't a signed angle
well it's only signed if you choose
clockwise or counterclockwise is it
actually return to sign thing what is a
matter of defining what angle you are
picking so you use the sign because you
see what is contact clockwise on the way
you measure things on you're using mod 2
pi all right it doesn't in fact have a
sign it's just the mod 2 pi result
always always in the interval 0 to 2 pi
is that correct right
but sure the key thing is to define what
is that cone the actual angle and planar
angle gives you then the length of the
arc so how do we define actually the
cone when you kill you say P goes to q1
q2
but it doesn't seem self-evident Charles
that that probably should say it in this
documentation that the it always returns
something in the range 0 to PI as
opposed to minus PI to PI for it I think
it says I think he's somewhere I don't
see it here oh no
well implicitly it does okay I was
seeing in your other documentation
somewhere something where you had a
second
in one of these I guess it was in
triangle Center maybe triangle construct
further down in the future ice note oh
yeah that way you're saying the infinite
line of the Huff line I would like
something like that for angle bisector
where you can specify that you want the
infinite line that kind of squashes some
of these cases into the same case or you
might just want the Ray or you might
just want the line segment so we would
probably need some kind of spec for what
angle are we bisecting and a spec for
what type of but it's going to be the
same type of thing as you get here where
it's well you want all three of these
things angle bisector interior infinite
line all three of those irrelevant angle
bisector exterior infinite line exactly
you could have that in the triangle
construct case is basically the same
thing as the angle bisector yes there
would be my preferences for a triangle
construct would be a list with interior
and infinite line and angle bisector
would be a function that could take up
to three arguments did we have as the
string argument for triangle contract do
we have exterior angle bisector yeah we
do that's that's another thing like so
when we cherry angles are handled with
the string argument an angle bisector
just interior versus exterior whereas
here we need to legitimately different
string arguments for exterior angle
whatever's an interior angle whatever's
and then also different ones for whether
it's a CBN or whatever and I don't think
that's ideal okay hold on so here we've
got an explicit exterior angle bisector
here you're proposing a string argument
to angle bisector line that says which
angle bisector we're talking about and
what kind do you want it to be an
infinite line do you want it to be the
Ray do you want to just extend to the
opposite side of the triangle oh gosh a
live segment like that yeah because
that's also important and I think you're
like these function
they're kind of over-engineered enough I
feel like well but it's a big pain to a
consistency look I think okay I think
what we should do whatever angle by said
okay here's my suggestion angle bisector
line returns an infinite line object
okay
then we have the notion in here of angle
bisector segment which is the finite
line that ends on the other side of a
triangle now you've also got is this
well-defined given that you have a
particular vertex P don't you need to
know the second vertex to define an
exterior angle bisector no because this
has no way of specifying a half line
this always is either the line segment
or an infinite line well right now but
you're proposing that it might have a
half line but I see but you're saying
without the half line it doesn't matter
which one you're talking argument they
will also have it well fine but I
suggest adding the angle bisector
segment that means the finite line
ending on the other side of the triangle
that's what we are calling angle
bisecting cvn right there second from
the top that is a much more obscure name
for the same concept so I had literally
never heard of Assyrian so I want I want
to just do a little poll here Roger had
you heard of these things
no not CBN Charles well I did someone
the first time yeah when we did the
design but no the
was talking about pre having heard of it
okay I will say so what about the other
people in here I mean like myself but
but didn't exactly know what it is it's
one where like I hadn't I was in exactly
where of it but once I saw it and once I
was aware of it I started seeing it
everywhere
you mean the wood or the concept the
word well okay like if once I knew oh
this is a thing I should pay attention
to what is it what does the would come
from is it named after a saver
so like remember save as save as theorem
is it's a it's a theorem e we use a lot
as an example for the geometric scene
project but anyway the the guy save has
did a lot of triangle work so this is
named after him I personally think angle
bisecting segment would be more clear
what it actually is than the Seon thing
right so not want the list with infinite
line there how I no I do not I think
that's a total mess right okay and also
if you wanted that sort of list or
something I think we have you can get a
cien endpoint so that will give you a
you know you can construct whatever half
line or whatever you want as long as you
have the two points which you can get
you guys to do half line of triangle but
by the way I have a question here so Bob
on our live stream is saying good test
would be to translate Euclid's elements
into this well guess what we've been
doing that but I actually haven't seen
that could could somebody show that for
a second because I'd like to see roughly
what that looks like as an indication
how these functions are working yeah
they have some of that I have to leave
to it next on the meeting right yeah and
I also have to leave soon but so Michael
you you unfortunately you should go but
but let's let's take a look at this yeah
nice there's on the football okay I'm
gonna just pull up the tech conference
slides I'll share what I'm ready okay um
I I mean I just I mean and and maybe
this is fine but I would think
in the engl by sector function or if we
call it angle bisector lying I mean I
think it's fine to keep it as an
infinite line when you give it points
but they think if you give it a triangle
probably the segment is what you
probably look we've got three sentences
syntaxes here which we've not documented
so one of the angle bisector line of a
triangle another is angle bisector line
of the P arrow Q q1 q2 right and I might
argue maybe incorrectly that in that
case maybe this is nonsense one should
give it the result should be a half line
is that completely crazy because you're
distinguishing I mean I don't know maybe
it's crazy but but it feels like there's
a directionality to that I mean you will
much with planner angle because that's
the way plan angle was specified if you
give those specification the q 1p q2
that mean is essentially the angle
formed by the triangle point P but if
you do if you add like exterior as the
second argument then like I guess you
could canonically determine you know
which of these half lines to choose is
the exterior angle bisector but it's
still gonna seem rather arbitrary to a
user okay I'm ready okay let's take a
look go for it see my screen yep yeah
this resized everything yeah that's very
exciting area
okay so these are now entities is that
correct are they in an entity store are
they where are they they're in alpha
okay but so they are accessible from the
language is that true um their dev mode
exposed right now but should be able to
go live with 12 one what is the entity
type geometric scene really the right
name for it so some of these are
theorems some of them are just nice
situations they have names some of them
are constructions show me it show me an
example of the so Euclid book for
proposition three what does that mean so
it's nice that after a few thousand
years we can actually make this stuff
computable but why isn't given that it's
Euclid book for proposition three
eponymous people is surely Euclid
because it's in a pre-release state okay
well anyway what was that was the
computable version of this right so this
has a property called scene that returns
a geometric scene object and some of
these also have alternate scenes okay so
like take that take the scene thing from
that and let's take a look at it why are
those dots so far away from their
letters this might require the prototype
there's definitely require the prototype
I minded did all these scenes actually
get good pictures all the time um no
right I've just I don't know what
usually if there's a bunch of tangency
it doesn't always work great that one
actually looks so I about it pinked yep
this is a bug I think is already fixed
right there's a step up oh so this is
it's a construction so this will be for
12 - if you for the second argument if
you give instead of just a vector of so
this is the first present second step
you know a list of Lists in each with
each sub list is a construction steadily
it doesn't show much we've seen flatten
sub lists like graphics does almost it
used to but if you wanted can I make a
suggestion that you make this an
association instead because then you can
name the steps and then you don't have
an ambiguity named the steps then right
right well you can name them one two
three so there's a so currently for the
this branch if you do there's a there's
a canonical a canonical way it will
transform a non vector into a a list of
vectors so if you have a whole bunch of
crazy you know list structures here it
will find a way to canonically turn it
into something it can handle I think a
list of Lists is the right yeah I've got
a another design suggestion we've been
talking about that it should always be a
list of Lists but if you're not familiar
with the steps yet then okay fine
oh but I I'm but this concept of a step
wise I mean in a sense this is like
layers and a construction of some kind
I mean um and and is it the case that
these successive things merely add to
what is already there is that true or do
they can they yes like they only add
I see I see okay fine all right also to
take back my comment because I can
imagine then two forms of visualization
one in which you flatten everything and
just say I want the bottom line the end
okay then we'll that will have ways to
get both right so for example having a
button that is like the the give me the
end right wait a minute
yeah Arnie Arnie Dan what are you right
but yeah so basically they keep showing
that keeps okay yeah right so basically
in the in the big old PR that eita is
currently reviewing we have a like in
manipulate there's that little plus icon
button in the top right yes so we have
one of those and if you want to print
out the whatever do you matrix scene
you're looking at including since in the
12 to it'll be it's you can dynamically
move the points around you know whatever
you move the points around to whatever
whatever step you're looking at you can
just print that out as a geometric scene
so okay can you show me a couple of
other random things here so by the way
again I want to recommit on those hots
being and you could go down to a
slightly smaller magnification and those
those dots are too far away from the
letters for some reason I don't know why
okay but we go back to your list of
random things that you had so in the in
this random entities parametric scene so
these scenes so how many of these do we
have and how good have we done about 300
we've there's certain books in Euclid
that are relevant to geometric scenes
and we have all of them except for a few
have to do a circle arcs that we don't
notice all right supposed to be a second
what you say you have okay so only books
1 2 3 4 6 and 13 are relevant to why so
other ones a random arithmetic things
all the ones are purely number theory or
they're 3d geometry or they're really
specific about proportions and things
like that
if this as this is to this and
fair enough so okay so of those books
that are planar geometry what fraction
of the propositions do we have all of
them except more or less like five or
six propositions that require a notion
of a circle arc that we don't have a
good story for we do wait so what do you
have any of those up to tap your head
again cuz I do support partial circle
arcs yep you so in order to do a circle
arc you have to specify the angle
endpoints right right it says it follows
the circle that's not a good story for
representing Euclid you're not gonna say
this is the circle from angle theta 1 to
theta 2 you're gonna say it's from point
2 such-and-such a 2 plus so we need like
a circle arc through or something well I
mean you could you could have have
symbolic you know be clunky but you
could use symbolic radii and and angles
and then just set points yeah so go
through listen the as you say you've got
circle through and you also need circle
arc through in some way so I don't see
the point in trying to in to represent
Euclid these propositions with some
really clunky right well no not with
explicit angles I you know I don't
exactly know the construct that circle
through is generating the whole circle
and maybe there's some way to change the
circle through to represent the arc or
alternatively there's a separate circle
arc through which by the way seems like
a useful construct in its own right
right actually at the tech conferences
talking just a guy from industry who was
wanting to use and random enough plus
any way to get a gun so he wanted to he
wanted to use random instance the
geometric seen as a like to do like CAD
type drawings and one thing that comes
up again and again it would be
absolutely nice would be had this circle
arc through yep absolutely
except for literally like five or six
circle arc propositions we've got all of
the plane geometry from Euclid well done
and it really worked just and you can
you can write all that stuff out and
there are typesetting form for that that
good go down again
is there a nicer typesetting form for
that geometric scene that you have there
no right now abstract scene formats like
this in a concrete scene is that visual
diagram can we imagine a better typeset
form for this I mean this is not a
summary box it could be weird to
sometimes be a summary box and sometimes
be a graphical thing this is more like
graphics it's a summary box it's not
really editable right right
fair enough I mean this is look this is
the computable version of Euclid so
that's what it looks like I mean it's
not unreadable um by any means it's cool
really cool um and by the way does does
Raj know on the list of upcoming things
for 12-1 does he have this on that cuz
kind of a major thing in my view and I
don't think I've ever seen it on that
list well so we originally were going to
do a bunch of these these geometric
scene updates for 12-1 but I think
there's enough design review that's
weird turns out we're gonna have to go
through that I think we're pushing back
to 12 - so that's unfortunate right I
think that should be looked at more
because I think it'd be really nice to
get this out but I think this entity
stuff will be ready for a 12-1 right but
right but in the if the you'll need to
flatten all of the scenes right we got
to find this site there wouldn't be
there wouldn't be constructions anymore
so it goes there's a question of if we
need to flatten it I wouldn't probably I
would leave it on family then like that
because then it can come to life in the
next version as something which has
separate steps
yeah and in version 12 version 12
handles this just shows you the end
result it reaches as if it doesn't have
steps which might mean some of them
won't you know well what you could do is
have a property in here that's called
construction steps and have that be a
list of geometric scenes which is not as
elegant but it will at least give you
something I think actually we can't do
that
why
we need geometric see nowhere colonel on
the Alpha side no no I what
but to do the to do that computation
that tear it apart but I'm not
suggesting you mean to do it dynamically
but you can do it as a computer anyway I
don't need to solve the engineering I I
said that's what I suggest because I
think you can do that on the client side
after I can look into it if possible
there all right if I can just sort of
summarize or make one summary point I
think given that you've wanted to change
possibly every single function we looked
at or certainly in close to that that we
should leave these as experimental for
12-1 yeah I was I wrote this I wrote
these suggestions up several months ago
I even though that's a disappointing
conclusion but I don't completely
disagree I mean I'm just horrified that
angle bisector is something we've had to
spend a substantial part of an hour
discussing um but I mean okay so anyway
my summary suggestion is the one that I
just made about the different input
forms giving different things by default
with probably the possibility of having
some additional string argument just
like we do in the case of triangle
construct that would give you a
different one if you fed in a particular
input form yep makes sense yep I'll look
into that um
okay a couple of comments on our live
stream including the statement this
appears to be a can of worms which I
agree with the
somebody talking about polishing
existing functions which we are
completely aware of and are very much
doing but that's just not the subject of
this particular meeting um um let me see
could we argue to have a pair of
perpendicular lines crossing at a single
element oh boy
no um ah Bob is saying looks like might
need some kind of zoom on the scene oh
yeah that's already implemented in the
current PR what is it - so - the the new
geometric scene will always format as a
dynamic module where you can move two
points around and there are buttons
where you can there's like a plus button
if you want to zoom in a - button if you
want to zoom out and then there's
left/right up/down buttons if you want
to okay so hold on is that consistent
with the way dynamic Geographics works
cuz it has a UX for that so dynamic
Geographics if you want to it has a plus
and minus button if you want to move
around you click just dude you look odd
but we can't do that for geometric scene
because we want to be able to move
individual points around actually change
the scene so that's that works is that
obvious that you can't have a click
target that is if you click on the
background you get to you know kind of
thumb it around move it around so it
works like allocate it it's a locator
pain so locator pain if you don't
actually click on a point it goes to the
nearest point so that's how this works I
mean it actually is a locator it's it's
it's uh it's definitely consistent with
locator pain because it is a locator
pain unlocated pain doesn't allow you to
have the background then click anywhere
and it finds the nearest one right is it
possible to make it to why don't you all
join all the vectors if you click
directly why don't you ask John well
that's really what has to happen for
locator pain where there's an
alternative bill right yeah because I
think I think if we are gonna have sort
of movability I just it's conky to have
to have another metaphor for that right
well so the other option is if you can
do like i shift-click or something that
won't move but nobody will ever be able
to distract Li yeah so currently there's
just there's buns you click on to
to move it left right up down like it
around that okay Ethan is mentioning
Lando's analysis book actually michael
has talked about that book and using
find equational proof on it maybe
somebody here knows about that that was
a the thing that has been talked about
yeah as a question but so again I was
just saying that's a jonathan jose thing
we we're not in the loop on that fine um
what about 3d synthetic geometry it's
computed so for at least four random and
since getting it to work in 2d is kind
of the edge of our computational
abilities just for it to run in a
reasonable time frame so 3d is we're
trying to keep the design open if we
eventually want to go there but you know
we're using IP opt for for for basically
all the random instance computations and
kind of getting things to work
reasonably in 2d is kind of pushing it
the the problem is this is effectively
integer programming you're treating it
like a constrained optimization yes it's
a constrained optimization problem sir
yes but I thought I mean now with all of
our fancy constrained optimization so
like Roger just does Roger agree that
this is undoable in 3d I have no idea
but right I read that I I mean I think
it depends on how they map it and what
kinds of problems
all right there more than one way to map
this to constraint optimization I have a
feeling that it is worth having one
meeting between you synthetic geometry
people and the constrained optimization
team right I would say so so certain
things that just kind of involve lines
going through points we could do but
there are more you know and although I
guess in 3d we don't really have a great
notion of
three D circles already so that would be
something where I mean I think it's
worth the discussion because even if the
simple cases can be done it's it's
potentially very valuable I have no idea
what it looks like you know sphere
through whatever dodecahedron through
whatever it obviously can get very
complicated and not all of it is
relevant right yeah yeah tanda
assertions about tangency are horribly
complicated because you had sex lots of
different tangent planes and God knows
what else and it's right mess well even
ingles
right I mean Engel only works in two
dimensions because that's the only I
understand because otherwise it's other
kinds of angles geometric seen 3d would
have to support dihedral angle and right
solid I think you guys should look into
it I think there may be a slice of it
that is easy to define and fairly easy
to implement that will be worth having
even if you can't do the absolutely
general case which I don't even
understand what it would be that if you
imagine what Euclid was doing you know I
mean I don't even know what the state of
the art of Euclid's style proofs in 3d
is I mean I guess the things I've ever
seen yeah it I suspect there are simple
cases that would be very useful to
people that you know for CAD like
constrain things that don't get into all
the issues of you know dodecahedron
through whatever right um we do at the
top of your head do you think it would
be a geometric seen 3d head or just
geometric scene would work for 2d and 3d
I would guess it will be a 3d head but
I'm not sure well we were definitely to
do that and I think about it because
there's yeah because if you just have
you know geometric scene of list of
points ABCD and then you have you know
line of or line through of ABCD yeah you
there's no way to know what okay then
that would also be better because we
could just say you know first you must
redo things don't look right okay yeah
this actually this is this is if we do
it that way then this is much more
doable
can just restrict the stuff that's just
not going most of stuff that would be
computationally difficult as stuff like
circle where we don't have we don't
really have a great way of representing
it arbitrarily in 3d anyway so you know
it's it's clear it won't be supported at
least for now
um spheres write spheres yeah we it's
the perfect shape if we support spheres
you know what else doing we literally
only support spheres okay what in
question here that I think is
interesting is about documentation of
Euclid's elements and what we're
planning there we should have a
conversation about how we exposed this
stuff there I mean so we have the answer
right so we're gonna have a
documentation for the entity type and go
into the Euclid's elements there's just
one yeah but that's pretty lame I mean
it would be you know honestly having the
computable version of Euclid would be
much more you know having an actual
website that is the computable version
of Euclid will be much more impactful
any like something akin to the function
site or from function cider that exists
right yeah but I mean why not just have
something where we have you know Euclid
a page you know just a version of Euclid
that simply has the computable version
on each page you know book for
proposition 13 the statement in English
as you have it in that in that thing and
just expose it as you know a computable
version of Euclid seems to me rather
useful and it seems to me like a nice
thing to do that highlights what we've
achieved with with them with with doing
this yeah yeah that sounds ok very
similar to more from function side so I
think we should well yes so you know
separate discussion about that you can
have me part of it we can brainstorm
about that a little bit um and Ethan is
saying put Euclid in the notebook
repository yeah well I think but I think
we can do even better than that um the
UM
okay two more commenting and then we've
got to wrap up and we unfortunately got
pathetically little in mystery
experimental ization meeting you code in
geometry makovski space I don't think
we're we're not doing that yet no it's
not Euclidean geometry it's men costumes
yeah yeah that's right
somebody's asking how my physics project
is going actually it's going great
there will be more to say about it but
that is absolutely irrelevant to this
discussion except for the fact that
Charles is getting all kinds of bug
reports and questions about graft
functionality um okay well this was a
little disappointing in the fact that we
really didn't get oh look at that we got
one out of seven of these things covered
today but Raj if you're if you're still
here can you move numeric array and
library link next to compiler because
those are related things okay all right
I got a run off here um thanks everybody
there's a very nice stuff I you know
really really impressive functionality
it's the angle bisectors is such a
complicated concept um all right and
thanks to folks on the livestream lots
of great comments much appreciated